welcome back an exciting morning here on
good day he's performed around the world
and this weekend he's going to be at the
west gate celebrating the golden era of
music yeah joining us this morning tony
award winner alfie beau joining us this
morning alfred good to see you welcome
it's good to be here thank you so much
so this is your first time now over at
the west gate performing in las vegas
you've been here before but now you're
actually being paid to perform instead
of just kind of wandering around like
the rest of the tourists
what are your thoughts as you're
performing here in vegas for the first
time i am i'm so excited i mean at the
west gate for one i'm going to be
playing on the same stage as elvis was
you know so using his dressing room not
wearing the clothes but i mean you know
no right
i may find a few but the show itself is
just so vibrant it's full of energy full
of life
lots of songs everybody will know and be
able to sing along to
some some of my old classic songs as
well i'm going to throw in there well
let's talk about that alfie a little bit
because um you're so well known there in
the uk as we're watching
you've done so much people may recognize
you from les miserables but also um you
know
you've performed for the queen i mean
you have done everything and you're a
tenor but that's not necessarily the
music that you love no and the show at
the west gate sort of proves that you
know we're doing we're doing a wide
range of music i am doing a couple of
classical songs that i've had in my
repertoire for a while but i'm doing a
tribute to elvis to neil diamond uh to
frankie valli wow all the hits you know
classic rock songs as well so it'd be a
lot to dance to and sing to you let's
come and see it and how much do you
enjoy you know the interaction with the
audience you performed in so many
different stages so many different
theaters uh looking forward to being at
the westgate and just the engagement
with folks and they get to hear this
music the audience have to be prepared
because i do sort of hand the microphone
out and get them to sing along
and then i jump in the audience as well
you know i'll jump into the crowd so
why should you be burdened with singing
all the songs exactly you know too they
need to work a little bit but just to be
clear that haircut's not coming back
i'm losing it so you know it's
congratulations you've got that rock
band look i love it i love it well why
don't we give a viewers at home a little
bit of a taste of what they can see and
hear at the west gate when they go to
see before yeah i mean i mean i sang
this song during the diamond jubilee so
i'll sing a little bit of the end of nes
and dorma for you which is what i'm
trying
vince
[Applause]
[Applause]
and i know our viewers can hear how
wonderful that is but i mean to stand
right next to you doing that it was like
thank you we've been talking about
soccer and rock music and all of a
sudden that's beautiful alfie it's very
good to meet you good luck at the west
gate hopefully we'll see you a lot more
here in las vegas
saturday friday and saturday it's still
on sale so go to the west gate pick up
those tickets and go see alfie do that
and so much more please come along that
was something